[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like the answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and Speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact during World War
two the deadly German u-boats were
decimating British ships so the British
came up with an unusual secret plan they
decided to make a gigantic aircraft
carrier out of a massive iceberg
after all icebergs were abundant free
and unsinkable crazy as it sounded the
idea was approved in 1942 by Winston
Churchill himself the proposed frozen
warship would be the largest ever built
2,000 feet long and 200 feet wide more
than twice as big as a Titanic and
enough space for 300 aircraft it would
sail the North Sea's at a speed of about
8 miles an hour and could withstand
waves of 50 feet giving the British a
secret weapon to hunt and destroy you
boats they gave the mission the project
name of project
Habakkuk based on Habakkuk 1:5 that says
look among the nations watch and be
utterly astounded but secretly the
workers called it noah's ark a small
prototype of the frozen ship was built
and tested by mid-1943 but then the
development of radar gave the British a
better ability to track u-boats so
project Habakkuk was abandoned did you
know the Bible said a very large ship
can be turned around with a very small
rudder stay with his friends were going
to learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 my name is
John Ross good evening friends and past
that I welcome back and he just got back
from a trip from Uganda Africa and we
are you back safe and sound let's stop
the program with the word of Prayer dear
father in heaven once again we thank you
for the opportunity to open up your word
and study together we ask your blessing
upon this program view of those
listening and will guide us as we open
up the scriptures in Jesus name Amen
amen
well pastor like he opened the program
by talking about rather creative plan
that came about during World War two and
that was to build an aircraft carrier
out of a giant iceberg and we were just
talking before the program about some of
the things that they were thinking to do
with us giant iceberg that probably
looked somewhat like a ship and they
were able to put 300 planes you said in
that was a dart game where yeah they
would be able to store 300 planes either
on the surface of it and they had ideas
about how to plate the top with wood for
takeoff and landing and and tying down
the aircraft and there'd be chambers
underneath they drill right into the
iceberg where they I feel like to be a
sailor on that ship I wouldn't need air
conditioning and it would
yeah yeah like via like a meat locker I
suppose but they they had some wild
ideas about what to do they were so
concerned about the German u-boats and
keep in mind an iceberg only ten percent
of what you see is above the water so
for it to clear the water 50 feet it had
to be 500 feet in length and so they
thought you know submarines can blast
away all day long it's not going to hurt
it
and of course ice floats and so they
thought they'd come up with a great plan
but about the time they finished their
first model they realized that you know
we don't have the war supplies to put
into this where we figured out how to
beat the German submarines and radar had
been developed the Allies were not
winning the war and so the project sort
of evaporated but when you read the the
report about it it was a pretty
ambitious idea I couldn't figure out how
they could turn a ship that was gonna be
2,000 feet long and that's longer than
aircraft carriers today and and then I
remembered that verse in the Bible and
it says in James chapter 3 verse 4 look
at also at the ships although they are
so large and driven by fierce winds and
turn they can be turned by a very small
rudder wherever the pilot desires even
so the tongue even though it's a little
member and boast greats that can boast
great things see how great a forest a
little fire Kindles and we're reminded
in the word that words are very powerful
though they're small once spoken they
can't be recalled and Jesus said in the
judgement we will give an account to God
for every idle word that we speak and I
think all of us struggle we think
sometimes you know we speak recklessly
or can God forgive me for the careless
things I've said of course the answer is
yes but we have a free offer that talks
about you know how to tame the tongue
and and just the importance of choosing
our words carefully that we'd like to
make available we have a book that's
called tiny troublemakers written by Joe
Cruz it's a
kind of deals with the subject of the
power of speech and how we as Christians
ought to build people up with what we
have to say versus tear them down this
is our free offer for this evening and
for anybody who would like to receive
this we'll be happy to send it to you
for free in the mail give us a call on
our resource phone line that number is
885 six seven four seven again that
number is 885 six seven four seven and
you can ask for the book called tiny
troublemakers and we'll be able to send
this to anybody who calls and asks if
you have a Bible Christian our phone
line here to the studio is 800 four six
three seven two nine seven
let's 800 God says it's 800 four six
three seven two nine seven so that's the
number to call if you have a Bible
question
looks like we have just a few more lines
open matter of fact looks like we have
just one so if you call and you get a
busy signal just ask to hold on we'll
try to get your call as soon as we can
and try and get as many Bible questions
on today's program as possible so just
one more time friends if you'd like to
receive our free book called tiny
troublemakers the number to call is 883
five six seven four seven and as for the
book tiny troublemakers write down that
number because throughout the program
we'll be giving you some other free
resources that will help in your Bible
study eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven well in just a few
moments we're going to begin by taking
some of the calls that we have and again
we want to thank those who are joining
us I believe we have some folks who will
be joining us on Facebook in just a few
moments and we'll be looking at Bible
questions this evening if you have a
Bible question our phone line here to
the studio is eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven that's 800
four six three seven 297 that'll bring
you here to our studio and amazing facts
and just a reminder we do have a lot of
additional resources on the amazing
facts website amazing facts dot o-r-g
and all of the resources that we
actually share with you they are
actually available for free for download
if you'd like to download it on your
computer or your iPad or
tablet whatever you might have even on
your phone and you'll be able to read
these different books for free online
right there at the amazing facts website
that's amazing facts dot o-r-g amen
well with that I think we're ready to go
to our first caller we have Ruth's
listening in st. Thomas Virgin Islands
Ruth welcome to the program good evening
my name is David how are you doing
tonight great and thank you for calling
your question my question is well I'm
from st. Thomas Virgin Islands and we
just went through two categories size
change and what I noticed that any
parking is for the first maybe two
months seven one was you know like
almost the whole island was like helping
each other and praising to God and just
kind of turning around and then all of a
sudden he was not to be were a lot of
them back to wicked ways which is really
sad for me because you know a lot of
them are my friends like people who
didn't talk to me for months and years
started talking to me and then they
stopped you know roughly asked to about
two months maybe
yeah after about two months of their
working they just start go back going
back to their normal ways and even worse
than before so how do you use is this a
Bible question Ruth yeah it's like well
cuz my question is hot what are some of
the wings that as Christians we can help
the unsaved understand that they're
running out of time and there's no time
to be evil like if you're going to
change just change there's no time to go
back your your vomit or say you know
right nest in the bottom was a certain
about five or dog gone back to his vomit
someone looking in the mirror forgetting
who they were how do we help people
understand without rubbing them the
wrong way without chasing them away from
the word yeah well there's there's three
things that you can do to try to help a
person one is of course you pray for
them the second is that if they're open
you share in
Meishan and the third is of course you'd
be a good witness now sometimes they
people get frightened by calamities I
remember after 9/11 we had record church
attendance here in California and I
expect across the country a lot of
churches experienced the same thing that
we saw in our church but then it kind of
it levels back down to average again
after a while fear is not the right
reason to serve the Lord fear might
shake people up and get their attention
and a few people will be permanently
woken up by some crisis and they'll turn
back to God and they'll stay close to
God but the majority people when there's
a crisis and they become very spiritual
once they're out of the foxhole it isn't
long before they forget so you need a
motive better than fear motive needs to
be a love for God and love for your
fellow man and you know wanting to know
God and know his will so yeah pray for
them be a good witness and if they're
open share information and yeah we'll
pray that there's a revival when that
happens you know that's sort of the
stories that we read about in the Old
Testament where the people of Israel
they would kind of walk away from God
and forget his Commandments until
something terrible would happen and
they'd be oppressed by an enemy and then
suddenly they get real religious and
there's a revival that takes place and
the Lord is able to bless them and then
you know they're prosper and them and
things are going well they they forget
God and I think that's true in the
experience of an individual you know
granted the blessings that God gives
that's right next quarter that we have
is Marcy listening from Illinois Marcy
welcome to the program
hi thank you so much I really enjoy your
program and also I watch amazing sex on
Sunday mornings on television oh good
yeah my my question is well let me set
it up might my my dad died two years ago
and he was a world war two veteran and
he was 93 years old and shortly before
he passed my sister was able to lead him
to Christ which we were very happy about
now a few days after the funeral my
sisters and I were in his bedroom and
his TV turned on and off by itself and
of course we thought that it was maybe
our dad and then there were a few other
strange occurrences that happened after
that the ceiling fan lights flickered on
and off for oh like a period of 30
seconds and then my sister that slept in
his bedroom after he died she was awoken
in the middle of the night by a nudge
and I know what the Bible says about
them oh your spirits but I'm just
curious as to whether is it possible
that our spirit or soul is it possible
for to linger somewhat on earth before
you passed on to heaven you know can I
say one more thing real quickly when my
husband and I got home we looked 400
miles away when we came home we had two
of our TVs do the exact same thing they
turned on by themselves and then turned
back off and that happened for about a
period of three or four days all right
well let me let me dive in and and ask
you a couple questions and maybe given
the answer to first of all do you
believe that it's possible for the devil
or for fallen angels to create signs and
and to you know create ghostly
happenings yes I do
wouldn't it be if you were if you were
the devil wouldn't it be well and first
I need to back up and just say you never
know there are things that happen called
coincidences and electrical flashes and
impulses and things like that do happen
you know I had a circuit my house and I
thought was haunted and I found it it
was a rheostat that was shorting out so
you know things were coming off and on
by themselves you think Oh what does
this mean well it turned out to be
purely electrical and so you know you've
got to be careful not to say whoa is
this a message coming through but even
if it is
you don't want to assume well is dad
trying to contact us by nudges and bumps
and flashing TVs and lights and what
would that message be but the devil
wants us to think the dead aren't really
dead and they're not asleep that they're
communicating with us somehow and by it
the Bible tells us in Isaiah chapter 8
that the living should not be consulting
the dead Moses said that too very
clearly the devil we know can appear as
an angel of light
the devil can pose as the sea spirits
as he did in the book of second Samuel
RT I guess that's the end of 1st Samuel
so we need to stick with what the Word
of God says I have no question in my
mind that I've seen supernatural events
but you know what are you gonna do about
that if the devil you know makes things
go bump in the night if you give it more
attention he likes to mess with this I
just ignore it and say all right well I
haven't I already believe there was a
devil before that happened so what's
being accomplished by it I'm in God's
hands these things happen and you know
what if you rebuke the devil and ignore
him he flees from you yes yes well I
mean this is he's been this was over two
years ago that he's been gone but and it
hasn't happened since it happened for a
short period of time but I was just
confused because because I do know that
the devil can you know do things that
make you think otherwise and you know
and but I did it was just you know the
trauma of losing him and everything and
then for something like that to
understand hey you know we are lost
several family members and you have all
these memories of them and you know
sometimes you wonder is there any way to
communicate or they still are they
watching us and these thoughts go
through your mind a lot of it's because
your mind is filled with memories of
them but you know Jesus said our friend
Lazarus is asleep and you just got to
believe that you're our loved ones are
resting in peace and yeah they're not
they're not trying to
guide us and haunt us and things like
that you know we do have a verse please
the acid chapter nine verse five and six
says for the living know that they will
die but that they'd know nothing and
they have no more reward for the memory
of them is forgotten verse six says also
their love their hatred the envy have
now perished Nevermore will they have a
share in anything that is done under the
Sun meaning that it's not a dead loved
one that might come back and do
something to kind of send a message but
they're asleep as the Bible describes
death waiting for the resurrection when
Jesus comes if their believer so the
Bible says the dead don't have anything
to do with life here on the earth now
it's nothing happening they don't come
back to their homes and that kind of
thing that's really of a study guide
called all the dead really Denton which
gets into the surfing more detail and I
think you'd find that helpful Marcy or
anybody wanting to see what the Bible
has to say about this the subject amen
well Thank You Marcy appreciate your
question I Mexico Lee is calling from
Kenny calling from Washington
Kenny welcome to the program good
evening pastor evening thank you for
calling my question is I was reading in
Samuel about when the Lord told Saul to
destroy the amount the Amalekites uh-huh
and so I went a little further with it
and I was curious in the Bible
dictionaries that I've read they say
that the Amalekites came from Esau his
grandson amalek correct and but I'm
confused on it because the Amalekites
are in Genesis 14 before Esau was even
born
you know some of the names are repeated
you'll find even in the in other words
Amalek there may have been more than one
you'll find in Genesis chapter 5 when it
talks about the genealogy of Cain and
then you read about the genealogy of
Seth they had some kids that were the
exact same names that it makes it very
clear are from different families you're
going to find a lot of eleazar's in the
Bible and and some other names are
and so that may have been a different
Amalek but I think the Amalek the desert
dwellers were descendants of a son of
our wasn't a sudden or maybe been a
grandson of Esau I forget
yeah the grandson yeah so I think that
the one you're gonna find earlier in
Genesis is just it's a repeat of the
name okay that's kind of what I thought
but I wasn't sure because I couldn't
find any place in the Bible where it
actually specifically said that Esau is
grandson emilich was the descendant or
the knowledge of the Amalekites
yeah most commentators believe that
because it's where Esau settled and
where this nation arose was the same
area exactly yeah yeah yeah okay well
thank you very much I just wanted use
another resource okay well thanks that's
been my understanding I appreciate your
question the next caller that we have is
Steve listening from Washington Steve
welcome to the program thank you I just
am curious to know when the when you
start on the cross did the Amazon animal
sacrifice system stopped on that day
when the curtain was rent in twain door
didn't actually stop until the temple
was destroyed in 70 AD well the actual
sacrifice on that passover was
interrupted by the death of jesus the
temple curtain was torn and there was an
earthquake
so we don't think the sacrifice was
completed that particular Passover but
I'm pretty sure that geez reinstituted
the sacrificial system and went through
all the motions matter of fact I think
for historian Josephus says they did up
until the temple was destroyed in 70 AD
so you know when when Christ died and
the veil was torn in the temple keep in
mind there's two taryn's that happen
when Jesus was tried and executed the
high priest tore his garments which he
was never supposed to do because we now
have a new priesthood we are royal
priesthood and the temple was torn
because Jesus said destroy this temple
and in three days I will raise it up
speaking of the body of Christ the
church and so that's why the veil in the
temple was torn and
so we have a new temple but yeah I'm
sure the Gees they probably went through
the motions of sacrifices again until
the temple was actually destroyed in 70
AD and then there they've not practiced
that from that day to the present okay
thank you very much all right hey
appreciate good question
next quality we have is Phil and he's
listening from New York
Phil welcome to the program thank you
very much appreciate it I just want to
say to begin with you really have a
great show you you know you stuff like
the back of your hand but you speak
plainly and I think you're getting a
right
yeah thank you you're welcome sir my
question is this Russia and Iran
traditionally historically have been
enemies but now they are allies and that
alliance extends to include the Assad
regime in Syria Hezbollah in Lebanon
Hamas and the Houthis in Yemen so my
question is are we seeing Biblical
prophecy materialized in today's
newspapers is this the beginning of the
war of Gog and Magog
all right that's interesting you would
ask that question because I just talked
about that this weekend there's a
two-fold answer to your question will
Islam have a role in last a prophecy and
I think the answer is yes the second and
pastor Ross can tell you the chapter but
there are prophecies in Revelation where
it talks about the seven seals that deal
with Islam and some of them are in the
past there are still some prophecies and
things that will happen in the future
in the last book of I'm sorry in the
second-to-last chapter of Daniel it's
interesting that it mentions this king
of the north and it talks about several
nations it says Edom and Moab and the
people of Ammon and Egypt and the
Ethiopians and the Libyans and talks
about all these nations presently
they're all Islamic nations but I don't
know that we need to take that literally
Gog and Magog in the Old Testament they
were enemies of God's people and you'll
find them mentioned
in Genesis 10 and in Ezekiel 38 in part
of his equal 39 and it says gog and
magog lead the whole world this as many
people with them and it talks about the
Libyans and it talks about nations to
the north and nations to the south in in
Egypt and it says they all formed this
alliance it attacks Israel Gog and Magog
were enemies of God's people it
represents God may God means from the
matrix or the came out of God the
children of God and so it's talking
about a two-fold a union of well on the
beast dragon and false prophet come
against the people of God in the New
Jerusalem in the last days I don't think
it's highlighting Russia but what what's
happening now with Russia in you know
Russia is sort of fighting a proxy war
with the United States now through Syria
and serious fighting with Russia through
the rebels and it's like kind of like
Vietnam all over again where you know
the Russians were supplying the North
Vietnamese and America was supplying the
South Vietnamese we were fighting each
other on someone else's land that's
beginning to happen again now in the
Middle East which is troubling because I
think America is mentioned in lastly
prophecy in revelation 13 well it's a
big subject you know I got anything to
add to that I was gonna add I believe
that if it's not posted yet the sermon
you just preached on battle of
Armageddon
probably would have a lot of good
information that might be on your
Facebook page yeah actually I think it
is I I did a three-part series I just
finished on is it Phil yeah I did a
three-part series I just finished on the
Armageddon and yesterday I talked about
Gog and Magog so you just go to my
Facebook page scroll down a few posts
and you'll see that you also asked about
Islam in Bible prophecy you'd read about
it in Revelation chapter 9 under the
fifth and the sixth trumpet and a number
of Bible commentators all the way back
to the early reformers identified the
fifth trumpet has been the rise of Islam
the sixth trumpet has been the expansion
of Islam and particularly during the
Ottoman Empire kind of an interesting
study very detailed
I'm given but that's many scholars
believe that's describing Islam in Bible
prophecy thank you very much for your
question and we appreciate that do we
have time for one more before the break
we've got let's see joy listening from
Kansas City Missouri welcome to the
program thank you so much IJ you'll
probably need to turn your radio off or
you're going to hear John anyway I have
a quick question I know it says to work
out your salvation with fear and
trembling I can't remember where that is
I was just wondering - Christian fear
before they die do Christians what
before they're dying didn't have any
fear I tell you what we're just if you
don't mind staying on the line joy I'm
gonna come back we took your question
just before our halftime break friends
don't go to wait we're coming right back
and doing more Bible questions we see
those of you who are lined up and if
there are some we still want to call in
with your question that number again is
800 God says 800 for six three seven 297
I'm gonna take a quick break and we're
gonna start off the second half with a
Joyce question about Christians and fear
don't go away
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aft vor
G are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history or what recent world
events are harbingers of the end are you
ready for the coming crisis landmarks of
prophecy offers clear answers to your
most pressing questions presented by
pastor Doug Batchelor landmarks of
prophecy is a contemporary video Bible
study adventure designed for today's
audiences presenting the landmark themes
of the Bible in a bright and compelling
way helping you understand the Bible
better and giving you knowledge to face
the future with confidence landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you keen insight into what lies
next in human history
if you'd like practical tools to help
you thrive and survive in the here and
now get landmarks of prophecy start your
epic Bible study adventure with
landmarks of prophecy today by calling
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
the four that we can be saved well when
it talks about fear there it's not
talking about living in fear because
Jesus said over and over fear not I
never counted but I think Dwight Moody
said he counted three hundred and sixty
five times in the Bible that it says do
not be afraid or fear not that's one
fear not for every day of the year and
then in Revelation it tells us the
fearful will be in the lake of fire
John I think it's sin is it first on
perfect love casts out fear for fear has
torment God does not want us to live in
worry and in fear he wants us to have
peace and so as you're referring to his
first John chapter 4 verse 18 there is
first on 4:18 so to answer your question
God doesn't want us living in fear but
being a god-fearing person is talking
about someone who has a reverence and
understanding the awesomeness of God
so that being god-fearing it is a kind
of an AW any of the great prophets when
they saw God they they felt this holy
terror but it's not the fear where you
run from God that's what the lawsuit
it's a love and a fear where you run to
God but when when Daniel saw the Lord he
fell down before him and John and
Ezekiel and who else am i leaving out
all the Bible prophets Peter James and
John in the Mount of Transfiguration
when they saw Jesus glorified they were
they they hid their faces from the glory
so we should be afraid of sin just like
I don't walk around afraid of
rattlesnakes but if I see a rattlesnake
I don't grab it I've got a healthy
respect Christians ought to be afraid of
sin and so when it says work out your
salvation with fear and trembling it
means just be afraid to do anything that
would hurt God or separate you from God
through disobedience does that help a
little bit joy all right hey thank you
so much for your question and let's see
who just lined up the color that we have
is barb listening from Washington barb
welcome to the program thank you yes my
question was in the day when God had
Noah built the ark and was going to
destroy the world what was the grossest
thing that the people were committing
that thank God to sent destruction was
there fallen angels or Giants and
intermingled with the women on the earth
and are we doing these things today that
caused the judgment because it says in
the end times there will be like in the
day of Noah all right good question
first of all we know what the sin was
because you read in Genesis chapter 6
the thoughts of men's hearts were only
evil continually so there was an
impurity of heart and then it says that
there was violence that filled the land
now there's a common misunderstanding
when it says the Sun in Genesis chapter
6 it says the sons that God saw the
daughters of men that they were fair
took wives of all whom they chose and
the sons of God there are the
descendants of Seth when they began to
intermarry with the daughters of Cain
they lost their distinctive holiness
through marrying unbelievers it's not
talking about the sons of God there
being aliens now proof for that would be
is if you go to first John chapter 3
where it says behold what manner of love
the father has bestowed on us that we
should be called sons of God and so that
you know I think that these are the sons
of God does that help a little bit and
yeah are we making the same mistakes
today that they made back in Noah's day
yeah and then some because jesus said
not only as it was in the days of Noah
Jesus said as it was in the days of lot
meaning the conditions of sodom and
gomorrah which are pretty rampant in the
world today and so yeah it's like I
think Billy Graham said actually I've
heard it attributed to Billy Graham I've
heard it attributed to his wife Ruth
Graham that God is going to either need
to apologize to Sodom and Gomorrah or
our world is facing imminent judgment
yes so yeah you're on the right track
and I think the very sins that you know
we're the problem back in the days of
Noah violence impure thinking and
immorality it says in the last days the
love of many will wax cold all these
things are happening today hey Thank You
Barbara you know we have a lesson that
talks about the signs of Christ's coming
mm-hmm that we'd like to send you a free
copy if you like or you're left to do is
give us a call on our resource phone
line which is eight hundred eight thirty
five six seven four seven you can ask
the study guide called ultimate
deliverance talks about the second
coming of Christ and gives you signs of
his second coming again that number is
885 six seven four seven after the study
guide called ultimate deliverance a next
caller is we have Dennis listening from
Arizona Dennis welcome to the program
thank you how are y'all doing this
evening doing well thank you okay my
question comes out over Cleese yes he's
nine five where it says for the living
know that they shall die but the dead
know not anything either has they any
more a reward and this is the part that
I have a question about for the memory
of them it is for Dawkins
now does that mean that the person who
died their memory is no more it must
mean that right because I still remember
loved ones that have passed away
well I think that solomon is looking
beyond one generation and he's saying
for the most part when people die and
the others go on with life within a
couple of generations they're pretty
well forgotten the living who are living
experience life they're they're aware
and matter of fact if you look at verse
four it says for him and this is
Ecclesiastes 9 verse 4 for him who was
joined to the living there's hope for a
living dog is better than a dead lion
he's just basically saying that even
though a lion might be it known as a
majestic creature once it's died it's
not conscious of anything a living doll
is more majestic than a dead lion right
has more dignity more purpose so it's
not that the when when dead people are
when when people die they're not
thinking any memories at the moment it
doesn't mean when their resurrected
they're not going to remember anything
because that's kind of like
reincarnation we have no memory of your
past life of course we're gonna remember
and we'll be judged according to our
work so we'll have some knowledge of
that it's just basically seen as the
generations go by most people are
forgotten that's sort of a theme that
runs through cleese II a steez he says
the the futility of all the stuff that
you do and you build all of Solomon's
the gardens and temples that he built in
his houses they're all gone they were
the most magnificent in the world but
within a few generations they fell apart
yes thank you very much all right hey
thank you I appreciate your question
next Holi is rainy listening from
Stockton California rainy walks into the
program hello hi this is Renae
yes it is and your question my question
is about vision is disg I still do
visions today yes
and pastor Ross will help me find it
it's into Joel chapter 2 talks about in
the last days I'll pour out my spirit on
all flesh nice is the last days and your
sons and your daughters will see visions
your old men will dream dreams and young
men will see visions I think is what's
that's Joel chapter 2 verse 28 Joel 2:28
George so what is it but ever since I've
seen the vision I've been so scared and
and since I and I've changed my life
drastically for the good does that well
I mean does that still count for good or
or or does it mean that I'm lost and I
didn't believe the word and I didn't
change until I seen the visions or what
well if God has spoken to you and God
does sometimes speak to an individual
through a dream or vision to try to
capture their attention and your
responding to that warning then the
Bible says and in Ecclesiastes as at
chapter 18 where he says that if the
wicked person turns from their sins God
will forget all of their wickedness and
they'll live but if they do not listen
to the warnings from God and they don't
turn they'll die in their sins and the
Lord is pleading with us to turn I think
it's Ezekiel 18 and I was hoping that
the probation because I know you guys
talk about probation is gonna be up
because we're a long time you know I've
been studying the word and that's being
changing slowly you know over the period
of times I'm back for it a few times and
you know and I was just hoping that you
know God didn't give up on me and my
probation is up and I'm lost I just
don't want to be lost
you know amen well that's that's good
the Holy Spirit's working
on you and I'm worried about the people
that have no concern and so you know if
you're if you're sensitive to the voice
of the Spirit and if you're still
feeling the conviction of the Spirit
that's a gift of the Holy Spirit because
one of the things the Holy Spirit does
is convict so Renee don't be discouraged
but do listen to do listen to what God
says in his word don't put you know more
credence in a vision than you would in
what the Bible says but God may speak to
you personally through you know a vision
or a conviction but mostly it's follow
the word and you're safe you're building
okay I've been following it and stuff
but you know like I said it was just
changing me slowly you know I you know
I've been you know backslide and you
know but this time I I'm really serious
I'm I'm not playing no more you know
what will really help you and I promise
you I promise you if you've not done it
before if you sign up for the amazing
facts Bible study guide going through
this series it's a series of Bible
studies it will inspire you with more
power through the study of thy word so I
have already know the whole fourteenth
series I've done them all already well
we've got twenty eight of them that
we've got twenty eight you maybe haven't
done the last thirteen okay I've done
fourteen yeah if you go online yeah and
you'll get you'll get the best is yet to
come so you can contact amazing facts
you can do them online or they'll
they'll send you the actual studies just
call our resource phone line tell them
you'd like to continue with the amazing
fast correspondence Bible school and
we'll finish up you'll end up doing old
twenty seven lessons the number is 883
five six seven four seven and asks again
to enroll in free amazing facts Bible
school program the next call is Kortney
listening from Michigan Courtney walk to
the program thank you thanks for calling
yes all right
good evening I'm grace God for what you
what you do so my question was is it
possible to have grieved away the Holy
Spirit but
to still biron by much resistance but to
still desire him I know you kind of just
answered that with a previous call or a
little bit but yeah I think you're being
more specific about it well first of all
is it possible to grieve away the spirit
yes most people I talk to that are
concerned they've grieved away the
spirit in my opinion they haven't
they're just under great conviction and
that's usually the Holy Spirit working
on them when you look at the examples in
the Bible of people that grieve away the
spirit like Judas or Balaam or King Saul
or if the FEL there's there's a number
of stories where people just they
despaired God wanted to speak to him
they committed a series of Grievous sins
you know Saul killed the priests and
prophets and and God finally stopped
talking to him and he ended up falling
on his own sword but you know Peter when
he denied Christ three times he denied
Christ and the Jesus looked at him with
a look of love and he went out and he
wept bitterly and now Jesus did ask him
Peter do you really love me do you love
me do you love me well he ended up
becoming one of the greatest apostles so
he obviously didn't commit the
unpardonable sin but he was under great
conviction for his denial now some of us
have denied Christ no all of us probably
listening have at some point denied
Christ in our behavior and its
persistence in doing that that leads to
grieving away the Holy Spirit so God is
very patient praise God I'd be in
trouble if he wasn't patient he's very
patient with us and he works with us
over the course of years he loves us
more than a parent loves their child
like the prodigal son who wandered for
years and yet the father received him
back so if we hear God calling and we
respond he will always receive us with
open arms
grieving away the end our grieving way
the Holy Spirit means you've really lost
your capacity to even repent and come
home but if a person still has a desire
to turn back to God that's the Holy
Spirit working in their heart all right
our next caller that we have is let's
see Brian
Brian listening from New York are you
there yes hello thank you for taking my
call I thank you yes my question
concerns on Revelation chapter 7 where
it talks about the 144,000 in Revelation
chapter 7 verse 4 and and then also
farther down at that chapter revelation
7 verse 9 and it mentioned a number
which no man can number right and I've
always had concern with that 144,000
because my understanding of that reading
the whole chapter is that it seems to
describe the number of faithful people
who will be on the earth when Jesus
comes the second time and you're what
are you wondering are that is that the
only amount that's saved no I know
that's not the only amount that's safe
but is that going to be the only amount
of people living on the earth who never
see death that are faithful that will be
saved because I see the earth the
population of the seven point six
billion and if we're saying okay when
Jesus comes in addition to the people
that will be resurrected
there's only 144,000 that will actually
be living on the earth that are faithful
that will be translated no I don't think
so I think that the key to the hundred
and forty-four thousand is in the number
when you look at the number twelve that
was an important number to Jesus he
picked twelve apostles and when Jesus
killed himself Acts chapter one they
decided to elect one more to replace him
so they would preserve the number twelve
you remember and God not only saved the
twelve apostles but there was a hundred
and twenty in the upper room that got
filled with the Holy Spirit at Pentecost
and then a great multitude was baptized
through their preaching I think the
number is a key to a special group that
are like last day apostles now Jesus had
twelve apostles that went to the lost
sheep of the house of Israel for his
first coming when he comes the second
time he's gonna have twelve times twelve
thousand and so this is sort of a symbol
for the
they apostles that do a mighty work and
there's a great conversion a great
revival of people that are safe through
their influence how many will be living
when Jesus comes I think there's a great
multitude you know if but you know even
if you had a ten million and when Jesus
comes we almost have 8 billion in the
world now suppose you know there's 10
billion in the world if he's got 10
million when he comes it's still not
very many you know compared to the world
so the the save will be in they will be
the minority when Jesus comes uh you
know Jesus had few there be that find it
but I think it's gonna be a lot more
than hundred and forty four thousand
that number sort of is a it's it
represents leadership you had twelve
tribes in the Old Testament twelve
judges in the Old Testament twelve
Prince's in the Old Testament twelve
apostles in the New Testament
so twelve represents leaders 144,000 is
a group of spirit filled leaders and I
have a book on that I'll send you a free
copy sure thank you just like that a
pastor also give you the number please
yeah the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
you can ask to the book called
understanding the hundred and forty-four
thousand called who will sing the song
that number again is 800 eight three
five six seven four seven nicknames for
the book understanding 144,000 will be
able to send this to anybody who calls
and asks the next caller that we have is
Chris and he is listening in New Mexico
Chris welcome to the program yes you're
on the air oh good evening so I have a
question that it really bothered me for
quite some time and it's a reference
into marriage Matthew 22 verse 29
through 30
Jesus is responding to one that says
he's questioning that there's no
marriage in heaven
I'm just paraphrasing mm-hmm so my
question is I mean there's a good thing
I've been married 12 years I love my
wife and sometimes I think about that
kind of makes me sad because I don't
want there not to be married so why
would Jesus say
well I think the key is that is the word
marry is a verb he doesn't say that
you're not going to have a spouse now
let me explain that God created marriage
he gave Eve to Adam he performed their
wedding when Adam and Eve get to heaven
assuming they're both saved God does not
hand them divorce papers the scenario
that the Sadducees gave to Jesus was you
know one woman married to seven men and
who's she going to be married to in
heaven and Jesus sort of dismisses it
and said look in the resurrection they
don't get married and like but they're
like the angels and there'll be no
procreation probably in heaven but I
don't think if your best friend is your
spouse that God says when you get to
heaven congratulations you made it
here's your divorce papers now for
someone like David you know who's had
you know ten wives and who knows how
many concubines are Solomon that had
like 300 concubines and 700 wives I get
a mixed up I'm sure he did - that
doesn't mean that they're gonna be
married all these people in heaven there
are no new marriages in heaven because
we are not going to procreate we're like
the angels God told Adam and he'd be
fruitful and fill the earth well the
earth is going to be populated by the
redeemed God's not going to need
procreation if we married and procreated
in the new earth pretty soon we'd be all
fallen off the planet like bunnies you
know just it'd be too many people so but
will you and your wife still have the
ability to you know be married in heaven
I think so and so it doesn't mean
there's new marriages but I don't think
that God is dissolving the old
relationships
thank you all right thanks a lot god
bless next caller that we have is I
believe Lola listening from Charlotte
North Carolina
good evening evening thank you for
calling sir my question when Jesus comes
and the saved go to heaven are their
physical bodies immediately changed the
perfect form
the height and the weight the appearance
just like when he first created at Adam
and Eve or do they grow into perfection
slowly that's a good question
well first of all it says in first
Corinthians chapter 15 that were changed
in a moment in the twinkling of an eye
at the last Trump so when the Lord comes
we go through an immediate physiological
change from our corruptible bodies the
Bible says and we get these
incorruptible bodies we get glorified
bodies like Jesus had now Jesus body was
a normal body when he rose from the dead
and he walked down the road in Luke
chapter 23 were the two disciples on the
road to Emmaus they thought he was just
another person but then you read in
Malachi 4 it says they shall go forth
and grow up as calves of the stall I
think that for you know who knows the
first thousand years in heaven we're
gonna continue to grow and mature to
what the perfect plan was for our
glorified bodies what age will we be
well it's gonna be a perfect days of
maturity well you know we'll probably
look like we did when we were 25 or 26
in our prime Jesus died in his prime he
was 33 somewhere in there well you don't
have your wrinkles yet and you're
perfect and strong and am i answering
your question yes what was that verse
again accretions
well first Corinthians chapter 15 is
where it talks about we are transformed
Philippians says we'll get a body like
his glorified body and I can't I don't
remember that it's like Philippians 2:5
or something and then Malachi chapter 4
verse 2 talks about how we gonna grow up
in heaven yes okay okay thank you so
much thank you appreciate your call and
we had time from two minutes let's see
one get one more quick callin all right
we got Rebekah listening from Michigan
Rebekah welcome to the program thank you
guys for helping me earlier that's well
yeah you're on I had a question I was
doing one of your devotional and I got
stuck on a Bible verse Romans chapter 14
verses 5 to 6 that's the part where it
says one man regards one day above
another
another man regards every day alike are
you are you wondering does that mean
that we're not to regard a day anymore
there's no Sabbath no I'm I just got a
little confused is talking about the
ceremonies and the festivals and I just
got a little kind of confused on that
all right well let me see if I can help
you a little bit when back when Paul
wrote this a lot of the Jewish converts
to Christianity were telling the
Christian converts the Gentile converts
that they needed to keep the Jewish fast
days and they needed to keep the holy
days and Paul was saying look if you're
gonna regard a day regarded under the
Lord if you're not then to the Lord you
don't regard it in other words a live
for God either way but the Christians
the Gentile Christians were not being
required to keep the Jewish ceremonial
days in the Jewish fast days and so of
course this is separate and distinct
from the Sabbath that we have every week
one of the Ten Commandments and so they
had gotten mixed up in what animals they
could eat because they were afraid once
an animal was offered to a pagan god
they could no longer eat it even if it
was a clean animal and Paul was saying
look if your faith is weak and you just
eat vegetables don't judge somebody that
eats the the meat and he was just
talking about some issues that were
going on in the church back then you
know we have a book called feast days
and Sabbath's which actually look at
this verse and explain the difference
between the ceremonial laws and the
Sabbath were happy to send it to you
Rebecca why anybody who calls an ass the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
thank you very much listening friends
you hear the music in the background we
want to remind you that amazing facts is
only here because of people like you
that listen and keep us on the air if
you'd like to support the ministry we'd
love to hear from you just go to amazing
facts dot o-r-g and you can click donate
god bless well study his work together
again next week
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
[Music]
amazing facts offer some of the best
Christian resources for all ages we have
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the Lord
what does Bible prophecy reveal about
the world's two largest religions
explore the ancient conflict in Islam
Christianity and prophecy a compelling
three-part series with pastor Doug
Batchelor get yours today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767 credible stories from all
over the globe of lives that are being
changed and hearts that are being
transformed by the power of the word and
none of it could happen without your
teamwork with this ministry
god
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth Calm find
out what the critics are raving about
top scholars and theologians from around
the country come together to reveal the
hidden history of the book of Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95 minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word
visit our website at www.att.com/biz
[Music]
Iorek DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at $887 pack so RG